My eye doctor says it's that I have scleritis in my left eye inflammation. I've had this
before, but I just used apple cider vinegar, vitamin C powder, and inner defense oil, and
it goes away. She wants me to take predisone. What say you? It's been way more painful and
lasted longer this time. That's why I went in. Okay, so predisone is going to be a very, very strong
anti-inflammatory drug, and it will probably take care of the inflammation. However, it is also
something that will reduce your immune response. In short term, predisone use, is that going to be
bad? Well, it depends on if they're putting you on a predisone taper. We're starting at 60
milligrams and 40 milligrams and 30 milligrams and 20 attend such something like that. Is that a lot
of predisone? Yeah, well, yeah, it is. We have brain cancer patients that are on predisone daily,
but they're on like four milligrams. If you could do it naturally, that's going to be your best
interest. Do look out your right. If there's any right programs for eye inflammation,
run inflammation programs in your right, anything you can try to do naturally. You're going to be much
better than taking a drug. The negatives of taking the anti-inflammatory medications are they have
the side effects of reducing your immune system function. So if you could do it naturally, always try
to do it naturally.